[Applaus]
[Musik]
die
staatliche überwachung zensur falsch
nachrichten das internet ist zum
kampfplatz um die wahrheit geworden
digitale rebellen lehnen sich auf gegen
autokratische staaten im netz und auf
der straße
sie bringen sich selbst in lebensgefahr
angetrieben von ihrem mut und tiefer
überzeugung wenn du eine ungerechtigkeit
sucht und nichts dagegen tust verlierst
du deine menschlichkeit doch was können
sie erreichen
im kampf gegen die großen
propagandamaschine
die wehren sich mit aller macht
nicht nur autoritäre länder und
diktaturen verfolgen ihre kritiker
sondern auch vereinzelt der eigentlich
liberale demokratische westen
eine gesellschaft die es duldet dass
kritiker journalisten inhaftiert werden
weil sie ihre arbeit machen da gibt es
keinen unterschied zwischen dem
vereinigten königreich oder russland
oder china es gibt keinen
[Musik]
social media und die anonymität im
internet sind für oppositionelle von
unschätzbarem wert sie können sich
weltweit gehör verschaffen aber die
empire schlagen zurück dabei geht es
häufig um leben und tod
wang chen wurde zum feind des größten
und mächtigsten propaganda apparat der
welt
mitten im kriegsgebiet in der ukraine
ich bin ein chinesischer staatsbürger
der vor dem krieg schon in lourdes
erlebte
der 38 jährige wuchs in peking auf er
ist programmierer experte für künstliche
intelligenz und hobby blogger
[Musik]
es fing damit an dass ich beschloss
meine kamera zu nutzen um meinen
followern das wahre leben zu zeigen dass
ich erlebe es
ist ende februar die russen beginnen
gerade ihren angriffskrieg auf die
ukraine
auf der chinesischen
social-media-plattform ritschard postet
er bilder aus odessa
plötzlich fragen seine follower warum er
das land nicht verlassen die chinesische
regierung habe doch evakuierungs
flugzeuge geschickt
das berichteten die staatlich
kontrollierten medien in china
doch es gibt keine evakuierungs
flugzeuge
über diesen widerspruch zwischen falsch
nachricht und realität macht wann sie
denn ein video und poste des wetab
nach dem ersten video nun je mehr fragen
zu beantworten versuchte desto mehr
falsche informationen tauchten auf es
war endlos
wie er sich denn ernähren es gäbe doch
gar kein essen mehr in odessa oder kein
trinkwasser schreiben seine follower aus
china die chinesischen medien hätten das
gesagt
[Musik]
zu anfang haben mich einige nachrichten
gestresst oder mir angst gemacht gibt es
wirklich kein trinkwasser mehr besser
ich war verunsichert von den
informationen aus china aus dem
chinesischen staatsfernsehen
also geht man raus mit seiner
handykamera zum supermarkt alles ist
noch da obst gemüse eier fleisch
es gibt so viele gerüchte es geht um den
preis für lebensmittel es geht um china
außerdem sagen die leute das hier alle
nazis sind das fand ich völlig seltsam
was meinen die mit nazi
und dann mitte märz ist sein richard
account plötzlich geblockt der grund
dieses video
im video fragt er seine chinesischen
follower warum unterstützt ihr putin er
stehe auf der seite der ukraine denn es
handle sich um einen angriffskrieg von
seiten russlands die ukraine seien die
opfer
ich weiß nicht was ich in diesem video
falsches gesagt habe aber von da an
bekam ich ernsthafte schwierigkeiten
[Musik]
du verlierst dein job du verlierst dein
einkommen das ist ein sozialer tod und
das ist noch das beste was einem in so
einer situation passieren kann es gibt
noch viel schlimmeres nämlich folter
verhöre inhaftierung vergewaltigung es
kann mit dem tod enden
der journalist philipp mobile betreut
ein internationales netzwerk von
bloggern digitalen einzelkämpfern gibt
der reichweite in dem er über sie
schreibt ihre inhalte teilt und sie
weltweit verbreitet philipp nobel war
einer der ersten der den kampf von
manchen für die wahrheit gesehen hat
[Musik]
es gibt einen wendepunkt in diesen
videos an dem er plötzlich extrem
politisch wird über themen spricht wie
meinungsfreiheit religionsfreiheit freie
medien zugang zu informationen
erst recht nicht beim krieg in der
ukraine besonders zu beginn des angriffs
steht die chinesische regierung an der
seite russlands
russland ist ein wichtiger verbündeter
auch gegen die usa beide länder wollen
an lukrative wirtschaftsabkommen
festhalten kritiker wie orangen die von
der offiziellen propaganda linie
abweichen werden schnell zu
staatsfeinden
[Musik]
f hinter sei wenn er beschließt nach
china zurückzukehren wird er mit
sicherheit in irgendeiner form verhört
und überwacht werden vielleicht kann er
china nicht mehr verlassen
die chinesische parteiführung setzt ihre
autoritäre herrschaft mit polizeigewalt
und moderner überwachungstechnologie
durch
chinesische städte sind mit millionen
von kameras gespickt bei der polizei
laufen riesige datenmengen zusammen
auch telefonnetz und internet sind
komplett überwacht
verschlüsselungstechnologien sind
verboten
regierungskritik auch im netz endet
schnell mit gefängnis manchmal mit
folter mord kein anderes land richtet
laut amnesty international so viele
menschen hin und sperrt anders denken
der ein ende 2021 waren mehr als 45.000
menschen aus politischen gründen in haft
es ist wichtig zu verstehen dass die
chinesische zensur nicht auf china
selbst beschränkt ist bungie chang ist
das perfekte beispiel dafür
etwas das die menschen wissen müssen als
kritiker bist du nie sicher du bekommst
drogen es können telefonanrufe seien
morddrohungen auch drohungen gegen deine
familie
ähnliche gefahren erwarten dissidenten
in russland für ihre schicksale setzt
sich dennis scheer dorf ein und riskiert
damit seine freiheit und sein leben
jeden tag könnte ich als ausländischer
agent deklariert werden
dennis stoff ist ein
menschenrechtsanwalt aus russland er
arbeitet seit 2016 für uv de info ein
unabhängiges bürgerrechts portal
im info krieg in dem der kreml versucht
die menschen mit propaganda ruhig zu
stellen sind die aktivisten von vaude
info die digitalen rebellen ihre
munition sind informationen sie
veröffentlichen die zahl der
verhaftungen bei regierungskritischen
demonstrationen als einzige unabhängige
quelle dafür sind sie für ausländische
medien von unschätzbarem wert
wie
wir veröffentlichen die daten über die
unterdrückung von demonstranten gegen
den krieg in russland
über verletzte menschen
dieses mal ist die polizei noch
grausamer als sonst
[Musik]
doch ende dezember hat die russische
medienbehörde ovg info zensiert und
gesperrt
in russland kann man ihren inhalt jetzt
nicht mehr sehen es sei denn man benutzt
einen vpn
[Musik]
vpn steht für virtual private network
eine software für einen verschlüsselten
internetzugang sie ermöglicht
internetnutzern anonym zu surfen und
ihren standort zu verschleiern das heißt
über einen vpn kann ein internetnutzer
in russland so surfen die einer in
deutschland und so die russische zensur
umgehen aber inzwischen haben die
russischen behörden angefangen die
software zum teil zu blocken
[Musik]
digitale überwachung beherrscht auch die
straßen moskaus
über 100.000 kameras sind mit
gesichtserkennungssoftware ausgestattet
zugriff haben die geheimdienste sie
sammeln daten über oppositionelle und
lägen listen mit regierungskritischen
internetnutzern an
der offizielle grund die bekämpfung von
terrorismus extremismus und
spionage
mit dieser begründung gehen die behörden
auch gegen menschen bei
regierungskritischen demonstrationen vor
in den ersten 100 tagen des ukraine
kriegs verhaftete die russische polizei
laut evd info mehr als 15.000 personen
im netz tobt ein infokrieg
angestellte von putin ein troll fabriken
verfolgen zu tausenden oppositionelle
mit beschimpfungen und verleumdungen
verdrehen die wahrheit streuen des
informationen und hass
kritiker sind schnell vaterlandsverräter
so auch dennis scheer doch erst jetzt
schon auf einer webseite als staatsfeind
gelistet mit foto und lebenslauf
betrieben wird die seite von einer
kremlnahen bürgerwache
natürlich habe ich angst
und ja ich habe unterschiedliche
emotionen
auf und ich habe auch angst vor
verfolgung
wie brutal ein regime zu schlagen kann
hat maria maria schmerzlich erfahren
mit den folgen eines verhörs kämpft sie
bis heute
ich kann zehn bis 15 minuten gehen aber
ich habe noch einen langen weg der
heilung vor mir erst langsam aber es
geht voran
maria maria ist menschenrechtsaktivistin
aus bahrain das dort regierende
sunnitische königshaus duldet so gut wie
keinen widerspruch schon ihre eltern
lehnten sich dagegen auf
meine eltern haben uns beigebracht dass
man seine eigene menschlichkeit verliert
wenn man eine ungerechtigkeit sieht und
nichts dagegen unternimmt
im jahr 2011 bricht der arabische
frühling aus auch in bahrain
protestieren die menschen friedlich
gegen die regierung maria marias vater
ist einer der anführer der proteste
seine tochter hilft ihm koordiniert die
demos über facebook und twitter sie
dokumentiert mit videos und fotos den
kampf der menschen zentrum der proteste
ist der pearl square in der hauptstadt
manama doch dann kommt der siebzehnte
februar 2011
es war gegen 23 uhr nachts die leute
schliefen und jemand kam angerannt
kleine kinder sie riefen sie kommen sie
kommen ich erinnere mich wie die
blinkenden blauen lichter langsam die
ganze brücke einnahmen die
bereitschaftspolizei kam heraus und ohne
vorwarnung begann sie zu schießen
mariam al faraj entkommt der gewalt ihr
vater auch vorerst
er sagte mir du gehst raus und sorgt
dafür dass wir nicht in vergessenheit
geraten du sagst dafür dass die leute
bei uns reden dass sie wissen was mit
uns passiert
maria wagner verlässt das land im
letzten moment
sie haben den kreisverkehr geräumt sie
töteten menschen und dann begannen die
verhaftungen und zuerst haben sie meinen
onkel verhaftet sie hielten seinen
kindern pistolen ins gesicht und warfen
ihn vor den augen seiner familie vom
dach und brachten ihn weg
dann wird auch ihr vater verhaftet
ich habe mir den twitter-account meiner
schwester angesehen dort erzählte sie
genau was passiert war wie sie kamen wie
sie einschlugen wie sie ihn die treppe
hinunter schleppten und sein blut auf
jeder stufe war dass wir nicht wissen ob
er tot oder lebendig ist und ich weiß
noch wie ich im zug saß und dachte ich
habe versagt ich habe versagt meine
familie zu beschützen
ein schock doch für maria malaga gibt es
keinen zweifel sie wird den kampf ihres
vaters fortführen
unermüdlich versucht sie westliche
regierungen davon zu überzeugen sich für
freiheitsrechte in der arabischen welt
einzusetzen denn die bedrohung ist real
[Musik]
2013 wird bekannt dass der bahrainische
staat mit software britisch-deutschen
gamma group telefone und computer von
oppositionellen überwacht haben soll
auch eine frühere tochterfirma von
siemens sowie chor soll überwachungs
software geliefert haben sogenannte
trojaner sie schleusen schadcode zum
beispiel in form von links oder einem
angehängten dokument auf handys computer
oder tablets klicken die opfer darauf
haben überwacher den kompletten zugriff
sie können telefonate belauschen sms
suchanfragen und e-mails mitlesen
standorte erfasst einfach alles
eine gefahr nicht nur für die
dissidenten selbst sondern für alle mit
denen sie digital in kontakt sind sich
gegen diese art von hochprofessioneller
überwachung zu schützen ist so gut wie
unmöglich die ausgespähten erfahren oft
nie dass sie überwacht werden bis sie
verhaftet werden
mariam al khawaja hat solche angriffe
bisher abgewehrt wo sie kann benutzt die
krypto apps und verschlüsselte e-mails
weltweit trainiert sie aktivisten in
digitaler sicherheit
bedrohungen bis hin zum tod scheinen für
regierungskritiker im westen weit weg
doch in einzelnen fällen schlagen auch
länder wie die usa hart zu wenn sie sich
massiv angegriffen für
andy müller maguhn ist im vorstand der
bau holland stiftung die journalistin
und whistleblower unterstützt
etwas boden ist sicherlich ein gutes
beispiel dazu der eben als ehemaliger
mitarbeiter der us-geheimdienste sachen
öffentlich gemacht hat und dafür ja auch
mit dem tode bedroht wurde und das ist
jetzt irgendwie in märkten mit ihrer
witze geschichte dass er ausgerechnet in
russland gelangen gelandet ist ebenso im
visier der usa julian assange die wau
holland stiftung zahlt einen teil der
anwaltskosten des journalisten im streit
um seine auslieferung von großbritannien
an die usa
also wie kriegst hat ja dieses video
veröffentlicht wo es im lied er
angehörige reuters
journalisten einfach erschießen und das
ist zwar nicht als kriegsverbrechen
abgeurteilt erfüllt aber alle kriterien
das hat ja auch die un analysiert
und die us-regierung steht trotzdem auf
den standpunkt dass es eben geheimes
video material war und es ist ein
verbrechen ist das öffentlich zu machen
jetzt wollen die usa assange wegen
spionage anklage der eigentlich
problematischen teil das der dass die
us-regierung lange also ein garant der
informationsfreiheit auf der presse und
medienfreiheit galt und dadurch dass die
jetzt das prinzip über bord geworfen
haben gibt es eben viele an regierungen
die sich dadurch quasi ermutigt fühlen
jetzt auch gegen journalisten vorzugehen
und deswegen hat dieser fall assange und
wikileaks in ganz grundlegende bedeutung
völlig unabhängig davon ob man den mann
sein kann oder nicht so das geht hier
tatsächlich um den kern der
pressefreiheit
[Musik]
stella assange ist die frau von julian
assange der journalist und publizist
sitzt seit drei jahren im
hochsicherheitsgefängnis in london ohne
urteil weil
er beweise dafür veröffentlicht hat dass
die größte supermacht der welt die
vereinigten staaten im irak und in
afghanistan verbrechen gegen die
zivilbevölkerung begangen und in
guantanamo bay gefoltert haben er hat
die supermacht bloßgestellt und jetzt
rächt sich die supermacht
jetzt hat die britische regierung seiner
auslieferung an die usa zugestimmt
dort drohen ihm 175 jahre haft
für stella assange die als juristin auch
teil von julien assange anwalt team ist
ist dies schwer zu ertragen sie geht
davon aus dass ihr mann im gefängnis
sterben wird entweder durch selbstmord
oder durch die folgen von einzelhaft und
isolation es geht also wirklich um leben
und tod es geht hier um alles
das paar hat zwei söhne
stähler assange sagt sie habe manchmal
das gefühl in zwei verschiedenen
realitäten zu leben auf der einen seite
das leben mit ihren kindern alltag
gespräche in der schule auf der anderen
seite ihr mann weitestgehend in
isolationshaft in einem westeuropäischen
land die realität ist dass ein
unschuldiger mann mitten in london
inhaftiert ist seit drei jahren weil er
kriegsverbrechen und den mord an
zivilisten aufgedeckt hat in was für
einer welt leben hier
die regierung der usa sieht das anders
sie will julian assange wegen spionage
und der gefährdung der nationalen
sicherheit anklagen die cia soll sogar
geplant haben julian assange umzubringen
das geht aus einer recherche von yahoo
news vom september 2021 hervor ein grund
2017 veröffentlichte wikileaks die
hacking werkzeuge der cia unter dem
namen volt seven
um in china ins visier des staates zu
geraten braucht es weit weniger laut
schätzungen gibt die chinesische
regierung rund 6,6 milliarden us dollar
im jahr für zensur aus
mehr als zwei millionen menschen
arbeiten im bereich der internet und
medienkontrolle sie heißen offiziell
meinungsforscher sind angestellt in der
propagandaabteilung der kommunistischen
partei bei nachrichtenseiten und
privaten unternehmen
[Musik]
die kontrolle ist so gut wie total das
land hat sich vom globalen internet
abgeschirmt und ein eigenes landesweites
intranet aufgebaut 1b internet
zum beispiel sind die dienste von google
oder metern der mutter von facebook und
instagram in china gesperrt
das gibt also kein gmail kein google
maps kein youtube oder what's up für
chinesen für alles gibt es jedoch
alternativen von chinesischen
unternehmen die sind von der regierung
angehalten die nutzerinnen und nutzer zu
überwachen
das läuft so die unternehmen setzen
algorithmen ein um ihre plattformen nach
bestimmten gesichtern bildern und
schlüsselwörtern zu durchsuchen sind
diese nicht von der regierung erwünscht
werden sie zensiert
die soziale medienplattform richard ist
hier ein beispiel sie gehört zu einem
privaten unternehmen tencent doch
tencent erledigt die überwachung der
wetab nutzerinnen und nutzer für den
chinesischen staat
es ist eine kontrolle der sich chinesen
so gut wie nicht entziehen können
[Musik]
richard ist eine software für soziale
medien an der sie nicht vorbeikommen
wenn sie an chinesischer staatsbürger
sind oder in china leben
ist ihr tägliches leben wenn sie gemüse
oder wasser einkaufen sie verwenden wie
zb wenn sie einen bus nehmen wollen
benutzen sie die widget für chinesen ist
ihr account so etwas wie ein
personalausweis
man kommt nicht umhin wieder zu benutzen
es man hat keine wahl
[Musik]
und genau hier auf wie chat ist wang
jian blockiert
sogar sein gesicht wird auf chinesischen
medien zensiert
orangen sagt sobald ein freund oder eine
freundin ein foto von ihm hoch lade wer
das gelöscht als back up beginnt er
seine videos ab anfang märz auf youtube
hochzuladen
dort hatte er schon seit 2011 ein
account nutzt den aber kaum jetzt wird
die zu google gehörende plattform zu
seinem wichtigsten sprachrohr
dort hat sich wann sie denn jetzt auch
mit anderen video blockern zusammengetan
sie haben eine union gegründet wer dabei
ist sagt er nicht zum schutz der
beteiligten ihr ziel ist öffentlichkeit
wird einer der gruppe geblockt posten
die anderen dessen content doch diese
strategie hat einen gewaltigen haken in
china gibt es kein youtube seine videos
können nur exil chinesen sehen der
chinesische staat hat ihn mit der zensur
im land selbst kalt gestellt
die staatliche verfolgung hat damit für
massiven aber nicht auf ich würde sagen
es geht nicht nur um zensur das ist eine
strategie sie tun alles um dich geistig
zu zerstören
inzwischen bekommt man schießen täglich
hass nachrichten anrufe besonders nachts
videos in denen zb ein maskierter ihn
als feind chinas droht umzubringen sie
versuchen dein gehirn zu waschen sie
versuchen ihre schlussfolgerung zu
initiieren in deinem verstand aber wieso
soll man auf das hören was sie einem
sagen ich habe meinen eigenen verstand
[Musik]
dort wo autoritäre regime kritiker mit
einschüchterungen nicht mundtot machen
können greifen sie noch härter durch
mariam al faraj vater ist seit 2011 in
bahrain inhaftiert er wird gefoltert
aber er überlebt schult das gefühl plagt
seine tochter unablässig
viele leute fragen mich was das
schlimmste gefühl der welt ist ich
glaube nicht dass es angst ist denn
angst kenne ich man hat auf mich
geschossen ich wurde verfolgt und
verhaftet ich war im gefängnis
angst ist schrecklich aber sie ist nicht
das schlimmste gefühl der welt das
schlimmste gefühl der welt ist die hof
losigkeit wenn man weiß dass jemandem
den man liebt schaden zugefügt wird und
man nichts dagegen tun kann
ich hatte das gefühl dass ich meiner
familie nicht beschützen konnte ich
konnte mein vater nicht beschützen wir
wussten nicht ob er noch lebte oder
schon tot war
im gefängnis geht er aus protest gegen
seine haftbedingungen immer wieder in
den hungerstreik
2014 droht zu sterben da beschließt
maria maria nachbar einzureisen sie wird
verhaftet direkt am flughafen
es waren vier polizisten die mich
angegriffen haben sie haben mich
getreten und geschlagen
sie packten meinen arm und zogen
mehrmals es gab einen ruck meine
schulter muskelriss ich habe immer noch
schmerzen in meiner schulter
selbst jetzt kann ich meinen arm nicht
nach unten bewegen
danach steckten sie mich in einen raum
wir nannten es den gefrierschrank
die klimaanlage auf die höchste stufe
überstunden der raum in dem die polizei
maria maria gefangen hielt verwandelte
sich in einen eisschrank
sie sagt mir immer wieder du wirst nie
mehr rauskommen ich sei nach dem
terrorismus gesetz angeklagt und das
könnte zu einer lebenslangen haftstrafe
film
und dann nach drei wochen kommt maria
maria doch frei und darf das land
verlassen
ihre beziehungen unter anderem zu rouen
und zur us-politik schützen sie das
macht sie dankbar und wütend denn sie
davon kommen ihr vater und andere aber
nicht der gedanke an sie befeuert ihren
widerstand ich weiß dass einige leute
meinen vater aus dem gefängnis holen
könnten wenn sie wollten
dass ihr kampf ihrem mann die freiheit
bringen könnte das hofft auch stella
assange die anwältin will jetzt berufung
einlegen gegen seine auslieferung in die
usa und dabei alle juristischen
möglichkeiten ausschöpfen
sollte sie scheitern wird julian assange
spätestens 28 tage später in die usa
geflogen
[Musik]
wissen sie man braucht pessimismus das
intellekt aber optimismus des herzens
trotz aller bedrohungen will dennis chef
den russischen staat weiter mit seinen
veröffentlichungen unter druck setzen
menschenrechte einzuhalten
für mich geht es dabei nicht um
opferbereitschaft es geht vielmehr darum
mir bereitet es freude wenn ich etwas
tun kann die situation verbessern kann
und
man vertraut darauf dass seine rebellion
gegen den chinesischen propaganda
apparat zumindest andere aufrüttelt
[Musik]
menschen die nie frische luft atmen sind
gehirnwäsche gewöhnt aber wenn menschen
einmal wach sind wird es fast unmöglich
sein sie wieder einzuschläfern
[Musik]